there aren't many superhero roles are
much up to spider-man in terms of
cultural impact countless hopefuls of
auditions for the part of Peter Parker
in his various incarnations over the
years including some of the biggest and
most unexpected names in Hollywood will
never know what might have happened if
one of these guys have been cast as
Spidey but it's fun to wonder here's a
look at some actors who are almost cast
as spider-man Heath Ledger Heath Ledger
will forever be remembered for his
game-changing performance as the Joker
in Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
but the lay actor could have wound up on
a good guy site if Sonia got in his way
in the wake of his death legislation
Steve Alexander revealed that his client
was the studio's number-one choice when
it came to Casting the lead in Sam Raimi
spider-man
the actor was ultimately put off by how
little he knew about the character
telling his agent he would have been
taking somebody else's dream away if he
took the part of our fully appreciating
spider-man's history Jake Gyllenhaal
of course the path of rama's Peter
Parker ultimately went to Tobey Maguire
and the rest is Spidey history Maguire
was propelled to a-list stardom after
the first film storm to the top of the
domestic box-office in 2003 but he
almost never made it to the second movie
after sustaining a back injury while
filming Seabiscuit in 2003 Jake
Gyllenhaal was drafted to take his place
though he was dropped when Maguire made
a miraculous recovery just in time for
shooting it isn't the only time Gellin
Hall has narrowly missed out on playing
an iconic superhero it was also close to
playing Christopher Nolan's Batman only
to be beaten to the role by Christian
Bale
Batman James Franco it's not uncommon
for an actor to come away from an
audition having failed to get the part
that they went for only to be contacted
and offered another role in the picture
this was the case with James Franco who
read for the lead role in Sam Raimi's
spider-man but was ultimately beaten to
the prize by Tobey Maguire
lucky little Kaplan jr. gonna cry
Franco confessed that he was
disappointed when the director called
him to let him know the part a gun to
McGuire though he suffered the blow we
instead offered the Freaks and Geeks
star the part of Harry Osborn son of the
Green Goblin and Peter Parker's best
friend Franco agreed and the casting
call for Harry was immediately withdrawn
Daniel Radcliffe when Tom Holland was
announced as a newest spider-man Harry
Potter star Daniel Radcliffe was among
those who offered public congratulations
to Holland but his compliments may have
come through gritted teeth Radcliffe
went on to reveal that he wanted a part
himself while also conceding that it was
now out of reach I would have made a
good spider-man but the boat has sailed
on that one I'm not sure if I'd sign up
for something that was another seven or
eight films or ten years but a shorter
franchise yeah he did get to a lease
live out his dream by cosplaying a
spider-man for comic-con though so
that's nice you know you don't go to
comic-con without going down on the
floor and seeing it all and so the way I
came up with doing that was spider-man
Leonardo DiCaprio just because we didn't
get a big-budget spider-man until 2002
that doesn't mean there wasn't earlier
attempts one of the big what-ifs in
superhero movies is the James Cameron
version of spider-man which the
acclaimed director abandoned in favor of
Titanic among the stars Cameron
considered for the lead role was none
other than Leonardo DiCaprio who read
the screenplay and met with Cameron to
discuss the role DiCaprio never did get
it on those tighty spidies but Cameron
gave him a pretty good consolation prize
the lead role in Titanic
and that's not even the earliest tried a
cinematic Spidey Tom Cruise after
several failed attempts to negotiate a
deal to get spider-man swinging onto the
big screen in the late 70s and 80s
Marvel finally signed on the dotted line
with Cannon Films a production company
known for churning out low-budget action
films Texas Chainsaw Massacre directed
tobe Hooper was signed up to direct a
script that actually saw Peter Parker
youtaite into an anthropomorphic
tarantula Tom Cruise was offered the
part opposite Bob Hoskins as iconic
Spidey villain dr. octopus but
unsurprisingly Cruz decided to pass on
the bizarre project but wait it gets
even weirder Michael Jackson in 2009
Marvel's legendary Stanley told
bewildered audiences at San Diego
comic-con that Michael Jackson had once
invited him to his Neverland Ranch to
ask about personally producing a
spider-man movie with the late King of
Pop intending to take on the starring
role himself but Marvel said no Jackson
came up with a new plan by Marvel out so
he could play the role when I told him I
didn't think the company would sell it
he then wanted to buy Marvel so that
I'll buy Marvel I don't know what
happened I mean obviously he didn't buy
Marvel but he wanted to very much yikes
Mahe he senses are tingling thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to